There are many reasons why the world loves
Jason Momoa: He stole and broke hearts on
Game of Thrones, he made a splash as Aquaman
in Justice League and will do it again in
his own standalone movie this year, and his
tattoos and hair inspire serious style envy.
But we have another item to add to the list:
Momoa recently took a photo with two fans
that the world can't stop laughing about.
Liz Medendorp, who goes by the username twoforjoy
on Imgur, attended Denver Comic Con back in
June, where she had the chance to take a picture
with the Game of Thrones alum.
She explained on Imgur,
"I told my husband I wanted a picture alone
with Jason Momoa, but he wasn't comfortable
with that."
So her husband, Anthony Mendendorp, hopped
into frame, but Momoa ending up getting the
last word when he used one arm to pose with
Liz and the other to push her husband away.
Momoa later added a cherry on top of the priceless
picture by signing his autograph directly
over Anthony's face.
Liz shared,
"[Momoa] was all about it.
When he saw the print-out to sign it, he said,
'This is f---ing amazing.'"
Liz later revealed to Bored Panda that her
husband's discomfort actually stemmed from
not wanting to spend so much money on a photo
if he wasn't going to be in it, and that Momoa
was totally on board with the joke when the
couple pitched it to him.
She continued,
"'Hell yeah!'
was Momoa's immediate response.
Before I knew it, the camera flashed, and
everyone in the booth around us was laughing.
As we were shuffled toward the exit, I heard
Momoa call out, 'My man, that's going to be
the best one!'"
Over 3,000 comments on Reddit later, it's
safe to assume Anthony was more than happy
to be shoved in the face by the mega-muscled
superstar.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!